oh ah it's already happens to everybody
today i'm on whitby island right off the
coast of seattle
i'm headed to an amazing basketball
court tucked right in the middle of a
forest
you got a little bit of everything you
got the farms
the wood you got coastline
i used to live you know out in the woods
so this is somewhat normal where you see
some beers every now and then
i'm headed to meet with jacob to find
out what makes this blue court so
special
hey this court is really nice we got the
blue in there the trees around here i
have a couple good games on this court
what's up bro what's up man good to see
you guys know welcome to your
neighborhood huh yeah
so how are you 17 yeah
that's good that's good i remember when
i was 17. so what do you want you want
to go to college and play hoop yeah
that's the goal i want to be able to you
know get a scholarship play for free
we're going to see if we can shoot it
uh okay what type of training do you do
like you know give cause i said you're
one of the fastest in the league like
yeah i mean what separated me and how i
was able to make it pro was i just
worked harder than everybody like i was
always at the gym i was always at a park
my best friends was always guys that
wanted to play basketball as well so if
you look at it like the numbers are
against you from the jump there's so
many kids in the world that's exactly
trying to play basketball trying to make
it so what are you going to do that
separates yourself from them
like that's only a question you can
answer like what's the story behind this
court and and then the importance it
means to you i mean it means a lot i
just feel like just because it's the
only court that's open to the public and
like the whole south end so when i was
younger i actually raised some of the
money for the court when i was my 10th
birthday i like asked everyone to come
and bring money just to donate for the
court and
you know i think we got up to like a
thousand dollars for that so that was
pretty cool
show me what you got it's your court you
got to show me something
all right yeah you dug it out
i got to get it now you got to this for
the camera
come on dude i got to jump with you
oh
showtime
appreciate it
jacob's a good kid it's just how hard is
he willing to work it was a long trip to
get out here but for me to be coming to
you know one of the coolest little
basketball courts i've seen outside made
it all worth
[Music]